there are many rules of logarithms and
out of those there are three which are
frequently used here's the first one it
tells us about the log of X Y to the
base B you see that there's a product
inside so the first rule states that
this equals log of X to the base B plus
log of Y to the base B yes this is the
first rule and it's called the
logarithmic addition identity when two
Logs with the same base are added we
write the argument as the product of the
two arguments the most important thing
we should notice here is the base the
base has to be the same only then will
this rule hold true the next rule talks
about log of x over Y to the base B you
can probably guess what this will be
equal to yes it will be equal to log of
X to the base B minus log of Y to the
base B that's the second rule and again
the bases are the same this is referred
to as the logarithmic subtraction
identity the third rule is quite
interesting it tells us about the log of
a raise to n to the base B here the base
is B and the argument is a raise to n it
equals n times log of a to the base B
the power of the argument is written
here so these are the three most
important rules in logarithms but there
are a few common mistakes that students
make while remembering these rules log X
multiplied by log Y is not equal to log
of X plus y log of x times y is equal to
log of X plus log of Y and similarly log
of X divided by log of Y is not equal to
log of X minus y remember that the
product or the division is written as
the argument not here now where do these
rules help us let's look at an example
we have been asked to find the log of 24
to the base 2 now most calculators
provide the answers for log to the base
10 and the natural log so assume that we
need to find this value without the
calculator
we are given some additional information
along with it the log of six to the base
two is equal to two point five eight
four nine six how do we approach this
problem we are given the value of log
six to the base two and we need to find
the value of log 24 to the base to give
it a try the trick lies in writing 24 as
a product of two numbers this can be
written as log of 4 times 6 to the base
2 the argument 24 is written as 4 times
6 now why did we write it as 4 times 6
and not 2 times 12 you'll know soon
let's try applying the first rule here
we can write it as log of 4 to the base
2 plus log of 6 to the base 2 log of XY
is log of X plus log of Y it's the same
concept we applied here we have been
given the value of this term but what
about this one do we need the calculator
for this this just asks us to raise to
what will give us 4 and the answer is 2
there was another way in which we could
have solved for the first term it can be
written as log of 2 squared to the base
2 applying the third rule we can write
this as 2 times log of 2 to the base 2
and we know that log of B to the base B
equals 1 and 2 times 1 is 2 no matter
what role or property you apply you will
get the same answer anyway coming back
to our problem this is given to us as 2
point 5 8 4 9 6 adding these terms gives
us four point five eight four nine six
let's verify our answer using an online
calculator the base is 2 and the
argument is 24 if we calculate this we
get four point five eight four nine six
our answer is correct before we move on
to the other examples we will prove
these three rules in the next few videos
you